let's try robin from aarhus
robin can you can you hear me yes
where is aarhus is that australia no
that's in denmark
denmark oh okay beautiful thanks for
taking my call david i enjoy your show
very much
pleasure it's very very interesting um
i'm a rather politically active myself
in denmark
uh on the left wing and i follow
american politics with interest and your
show is very interesting to listen to
you
thank you um uh i was i was just
wondering i'd like to hear your opinion
on something which is uh
one thing i've noticed very much in the
american political discourse
is it's sort of a lack of knowledge
about what's going on
in the rest of the world um like um
it's and it seems to me to be a problem
on both sides of
your political spectrum over there um
obviously the right wing is
totally oblivious about what's going on
in uh
in the rest of the world especially when
talking about things like uh
healthcare and the welfare state and so
on um
we generally laugh at them very much
over here um i'm sorry to say
um but i've also noticed it um sometimes
on the left
um where we sometimes have this sort of
feeling that
like like let me give you an example
when when uh when you
when uh you finally legalized gay
marriage in america there was like
huge demonstrations like this this is
going to be great for the whole world
and we're right we've
yeah and um to some degree i mean listen
i'm guilty of this myself to some degree
you know i do a show mostly on american
politics and that limits the amount of
time that i spend following the politics
of other countries
other than argentina because i'm from
there and so i follow the politics there
somewhat closely
but for example you know should i be
more informed about what's happening in
ethiopia right now
absolutely you know i have i have a
sense of what's going on and i've read a
few articles but i should be more
informed
should i be more informed about what's
happening in the congo right now
um yeah there's no question about it and
i think that there's one
aspect of it that i think is important
to recognize which is it is natural
that the world will follow the news more
of countries that are setting some of
the cultural
uh lines of sort of like global culture
and in that sense technologically
and culturally the us is very important
it's not singularly important so
to some degree it's logical and also
because of the size of the us i
understand why for example
folks in denmark are probably better
informed about american politics than
americans about danish politics like to
a degree that makes sense
but i agree with you that americans are
underinformed uh
globally for sure yeah just
my point is mainly just that um it would
be healthy because
i believe that for example most danish
people obviously not all because we've
got
loads of different different political
opinions here as well but most danish
people would be able to say
with a certain extent of accuracy what
most other countries think
of denmark for example um but i
i don't get that feeling from americans
uh i don't get the feeling that you like
if i were to ask
an american what do you think would you
rate what do you think this what do you
think that generally the idea of units
is in spain for example
i don't think most americans would
really know
well there's a couple there's a couple
different things there
i mean number one global opinion of the
us
was very low during the trump era
other than russia i believe
turkey and there was one african country
i forget which which had sort of like an
unusually high
favorability but most of the world was
pretty disgusted with the u.s under
trump
much of that reputation has recovered
under biden and so part of it there's
there's two things there
one is depending on who's president we
elect
sometimes such wacky people that opinion
of the u.s changes drastically
up and down around the world the second
piece of it is there's lots of
republicans who don't want to accept the
reality
of global opinion of the us and so they
whether they
know or don't know they certainly don't
want to accept it
no that's that's true but it was very
interesting to get your opinion
thank you very much uh for taking my
call david my pleasure
so are you where in denmark do you live
is it possible to ask
well always is the second largest uh
city in denmark it's on the eastern
coast of jutland
um wow i've never been to that region i
have only been to uh copenhagen and some
immediately surrounding areas loved it
absolutely loved it and in fact
when i was bicycling in copenhagen
a viewer of mine stopped me on the bike
path and said
i watch you from denmark and we took a
picture together it's on my instagram
yeah i i know i know several people who
know you
i mean yeah it's it's very interesting
watching you you you have a very sort of
uh it's a very objective uh you have a
very nice object it doesn't seem like
you're preaching
which is we appreciate that in denmark i
i appreciate your appreciation of it
thank you very much appreciate it yeah
take care very very interesting call
yeah
loving it absolutely loving hearing from
some of these folks
let's go next to how about zach from
west virginia what's happening in west
virginia with joe manchin
hey what's going on david how are you
can you hear me i can't
you're coming through pristine today oh
wonderful yeah um so
my uh main question was uh i actually
had two questions
that's fine one is is
it's kind of a vague question it's uh
how
just how historical do you think the
moment we're living in
like this decade in particular is
i have no idea whatsoever and that's one
of those things where you know i could
give you some hot take on it
it would just be a guess i i really
don't know we don't know that until we
look
back and and kind of have more context
i think that there's the potential for
this decade
as an important inflection moment
because in 2016
the u.s elected trump and we saw this
slide globally to authoritarianism
we now we may be getting out of that
or we may not and so i do think over the
next 10 years we're going to see
what are the following 50 maybe going to
look like in terms of whether this
authoritarianism and right-wing
nationalism takes hold or it's rejected
but to say exactly the level of
importance
of this decade i think it's we're really
just guessing
yeah that's exactly what i what i
thought as well
um but anyways my second question was uh
please
i noticed you sang on your show a couple
of times that you
played drums in a band now is there any
video of this band playing that i i
that we could see that's a good question
uh there there may be
uh if you went so the i'm not in a band
currently but the last band i was in was
a band
called tin fingers not ten but tin like
the tin man from the wizard of oz
and i think it's plausible plausible
that there are videos from what some of
our performances in the brooklyn area on
youtube
i'm not sure all right well i'll have to
go
i'm on a deep dive for that all right
please
absolutely yeah now we've we had some
great great material
all right dave this isn't the first time
i'm gonna call but
i'll i'll let you go you mean this isn't
the last time you mean
oh yeah yeah yeah for sure it is the
first time but it won't be the last time
all right very good
all right thank you so much great call
from west virginia beautiful audio i
mean whatever they're doing in west
virginia infrastructure wise big picture
it sounds bad but that call was a
beautiful beautiful call
let's take a quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because i'm going
right back to discord
davidpakman.com discord and we'll hear
from a few more people in a moment
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath
underwear a lot of us know all too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional
underwear especially this time of year
as the weather is getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with multiple ergonomic
compartments in the front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
twenty percent off when you go to sheath
underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear a shot
i've had a great experience i believe
you will too you can find the link
underneath this video and don't forget
to use promo code
pacman for 20 off